put them in the [__] cars put them on
the dust stop like [__] it let's go
you're in control my businesses aren't
really work from home Skype I'm in the
hospitality industry and the majority of
the Barista age demographic they want to
be influencers and they want to be
YouTubers why don't you start hiring and
put a help wanted sign that says help
wanted influencer Creator slash Barista
then people come in they're like what
the [__] is that and you're like listen
while you're at the stand you can use my
restaurant as your content studio and as
long as you're taking care of my
customers and doing what I need to do
operational every time there's downtime
make [__] content it's better that
they're making content for you I hope
that they go viral and quit because then
you can use them as an example for the
next person there's unlimited people
that are willing to work hard in gen Z
if I'm you I make I make the sign put
them in the [__] cars put them on the
dust stop like [__] it let's go you're
in control